katanji jackson judge who's up for the
supreme court goes before
the senate
and the confirmation hearings are
revealing a lot of radicalism in this
woman so on the one hand she goes weak
on child pornography cases then the next
one this is frankly even crazier she
defends critical race
theory but all that
even all of that is not the craziest
thing that judge katanji jackson said
during her confirmation hearings
the crt stuff the racist babies the
the kitty porn no
the craziest thing she said was in
response to republican senator marsha
blackburn
who asked katanji jackson a really
simple question this was not about some
really con contestable aspect of the law
some esoteric constitutional question no
the question was simple it is
can you define
what a woman is
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition
this should be the end of her nomination
she should biden should pull the
nomination or she should withdraw
herself in disgrace she should leave the
legal community she should be disbarred
she should not have any role in public
life because i guess she's just a big
stupid idiot
here i thought she was an intelligent
woman she went to harvard she has had a
long career as a lawyer as a judge so i
thought she
was reasonably intelligent probably
above average in her intelligence in
education but it turns out she's just a
big dumb stupid idiot because she can't
define the most basic category
in humanity man and woman she can't
define it
and she's so
glib about it her she's got such a blyth
ignorance here she's so she's gleeful
and confident in her ignorance she goes
uh
like a student in class first of all who
doesn't know the answer and is just
stalling for time
marcia says tell me what a woman is
and you define a woman and she repeats
the question uh uh
you you want me to define what a woman
is uh yeah do you have
gunk in your ears you gotta stick a gum
in your ear yep yeah what's a woman
uh
um hold up um no i can't define that
oh you can't define that
but no i can't define that i'm not a
biologist
i'm not a biologist
i
uh i'm not a meteorologist
i know when it's raining okay
i am not a um
gosh i don't know i'm not a an
astronomer
i know what the sun is
if you've made it through
if you've made it through
kindergarten i was going to say if you
made it through harvard law school
harvard undergraduate if you've made it
if you functioned as an adult in society
you should know it but no if you've made
it through
kindergarten
you should be able to say what a woman
is but this woman cannot do it she says
well i'm not a biologist which raises
another question if i find a biologist
who says that a woman is
a person who does not have
testicles uh would you
would you then go along with that would
you accept that definition
a woman is a human being who is not a
man would you accept that definition
no of course you wouldn't she'd say that
biologist is a right-wing fake news
you support
lower sentencing for even pretty bad
criminals okay that's kind of par for
the course with democrats these days
with liberals okay it's bad but i get it
you support critical race theory and you
praise it by name and you support the
1619 project from the new york times
it's a lie that america was founded to
to defend slavery it's completely made
up okay that's more radicalism that's
pretty bad
you can't tell me what a woman is
either katanji jackson is the stupidest
person in america
or she is among the most radical people
in america and i don't think she's
stupid
which means
katanji jackson is
at this point after her answer to marsha
blackburn she is by far the most radical
supreme court nominee ever to come
before
the united states senate to be confirmed
really spooky stuff sexual disorder
everywhere
right now text knolls to
989898 with inflation at seven percent
like it is now thanks to joe biden's
stupid economic policies that paper
money in your wallet is losing value
fast today an ounce of gold is worth
nineteen hundred bucks it was worth
about three hundred dollars per ounce in
two thousand i have been telling you for
years that you can buy gold from birch
gold it is your hedge against inflation
did you know there's another way to
hedge against inflation it's not just
gold you can also buy silver from birch
gold silver is also considered real
money and historically speaking it is
extremely undervalued right now it's an
industrial metal that is in high demand
for everything from electric cars to
solar panels silver light gold is never
going to zero the american dollar well
it's going down the drain right now
while precious metals are rising in
value thanks to the fed call birch gold
right now
they're the only company i trust for
this kind of thing do not wait start
diversifying text knowles kwles to
989898 to get a free info kit on buying
gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account there's no obligation to get
this info text knowles kwles get the
info kit right now text it to 989898
i'm so glad that you liked that clip i
did as well if you want to get all of
the episodes you got to subscribe ring
that bell
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play great place to
subscribe to the michael knoll show
leave a five star review and also head
on over to dailywire.com check out our
new three-part docu-series fouchy
unmasked you will get the true
never-before-seen story of dr fauci's
rise to power and maybe how to stop it
from rising to power again we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you